[Music]
well just like the classic egg drop
today you will need to design and build
a solution that will keep an egg safe
when we drop it from the top of our
ultimate classroom tower
[Music]
so today we are going to be doing an egg
drop challenge now i know a lot of you
have experience with that but this is an
ultimate classroom egg drop challenge so
there's still going to be some really
difficult aspects to it now the
underlying idea here
a successful design for your egg drop is
going to transfer potential energy to
kinetic energy over the longest duration
so the way that you do that is by
maximizing time of descent and also
minimizing your impact force so
effectively slow down your egg and
cushion its full make sense
let's think about potential energy
versus kinetic energy now if we think
about a graph of the higher you go
the more gravitational potential energy
you get right so if we have a think
about this as you know a graph going up
like this this is going to transfer into
kinetic energy as well and we were
talking about maximizing the length of
the journey and also when you impact
right so we know for example have a
think about you know what's something
that we know in life that's designed to
do this to actually take that impact
which might be you know very very sharp
and actually spread out that energy over
time what kinds of things do you know
that do these they know okay a parachute
is going to do that what else
an airbag fantastic um have any of you
guys seen for example there's videos
online of people doing parkour so
they're moving around off these you know
cool things and every time they land
what do they do they bend their knee
they bend their knees and if they're
like super fancy and on the right
surface they will roll weren't they it's
exactly the same deal right
there's going to be conservation of this
energy you cannot get rid of it you
can't destroy it you can only
go over a longer period of time so if
you have some kind of you know
break threshold right because if you
want to think about it in reverse
there's energy that's holding your egg
together as long as you can stay
underneath that even if it's the same
amount of energy over time
it can be distributed safely does this
make sense
okay so we talked before you mentioned
for example using a parachute so that's
actually um you know getting this out
over a long period of time doesn't it
before it even hits impact right
you talked about an airbag right you
actually are going to collide but then
the collision
gets slowed down so depending on the
materials that you use you can actually
also do the same thing with your egg
slash eggs right and then the other
thing that we want to think about you
mentioned parachute
we've got an egg here right i want us to
think about the different forces that
are acting on your egg that are pulling
it down pushing it up right how many of
you study physics
okay a few of you
physics and mathematics are kind of this
very these overlapping disciplines right
because physics is about understanding
moving objects but the universe that we
live in objects move according to very
reliable rules they're so reliable we
can create formulas and equations for
them right so here there's really two
forces that we need to have a think
about
what's pulling downwards
gravity right so you've got your
gravitational force here but the
gravitational force that is kind of
applied to your egg depends on well
how heavy the egg is right so it's not
just g the gravitational force of the
earth what else is there
there's oh yeah so i mean the higher we
are the faster it will go but i'm
actually thinking about the fact that
the egg itself could be a small egg or
it could be a big one so you're gonna
have
mass here as well this makes sense now
this is important to understand you guys
probably have heard this idea before
right
mass is one thing it doesn't change
right so you have a mass no matter where
you are whether you're here on the
planet's surface up in space on the moon
but this
which we call weight
this changes based on the gravitational
field that you're in right so this is
the weight force that's being applied to
you it's what's holding us to the earth
and also to your egg as it drops
now when we think about what's going on
here right this might be say a parachute
that you create so there's going to be
some sort of constant here based on
how thick the air is what you're going
through maybe you're going through water
maybe you're going through air maybe
you're going through high altitude it's
all different
and then this force here it's relative
too you know how like the more mass
there is the more sort of force downward
there is
there's something else that's
proportional to the amount of force
being applied upwards you want to
suggest what's going on here the more of
something the more you're being pushed
up against speed yeah so we would say
either speed or velocity if you want to
think about direction as well so if
something's moving at fairly so slow
speed
we would call this a linear relationship
so as velocity increases um air
resistance also increases if you're
moving really really fast right so for
example we were talking about landing
rovers on mars for instance right now
mars doesn't have a lot of atmosphere so
it's a lot harder to slow down and also
to get our
rover to mars in like a reasonable
amount of time because it's so far away
we want it to be going really really
fast so this velocity increases and so
in fact at such high speeds we talk
about quadratic drag so in fact the
faster you're going you square that
velocity and that's what you're
proportional to okay
so we've got sort of air resistance
going on up here and you've got weight
going in the opposite direction now
this is really interesting for me i'm
like eyeing the producers over there
because i'm about to spoil a bit of the
lesson but you're gonna find out about
it anyway just have a look at your work
desks for a second
see how there's several eggs
right
several eggs mostly you're used to an
egg drop challenge where you have to
safely land
an egg
those eggs are not for testing
those eggs are going to be something you
get to make a decision about as a team
as to how many eggs you're going to try
and save and your design is going to
have to take that into account obviously
more eggs
harder to land safely but there's gonna
be more of a reward now do you see how
that's gonna the reason i'm mentioning
this right is do you see how that
factors into this
as you increase the mass of what you're
trying to land
it gets harder and harder to keep
everything safe does this make sense
in this egg drop challenge a successful
design will transfer potential energy to
kinetic energy over the longest duration
so we want to maximize the time of
descent and we also want to minimize the
impact force get it as low as possible
now
this is actually a perfect example this
challenge of where mathematical
reasoning is really important because
when you've got precious cargo right you
don't just want to experiment and test
and just see what happens you actually
need to use the mathematics and the
equations to let you know what's going
to happen before you actually do
anything so good luck i can't wait to
see what designs you come up with our
team scramble to protect their precious
cargo how many are you going to try and
save all of them
you